island ist das wohl am stärksten
isolierte land der welt natürlich nicht
zur nordkorea sondern rein geografisch
denn der sprechenden über eine insel
mitten im atlantik die von etwas mehr
als 350.000 menschen bevölkert wird mit
anderen worten jedes new yorker
stadtviertel hat mehr einwohner von
reykjavik bis oslo in norwegen sind ist
über 2500 kilometer allerdings ist
island im gegensatz zu nordkorea eines
der wohlhabendsten länder der welt und
reykjavik könnte der internationale
hauptstadt einer sehr hätten industrie
lernen island ein paradies für crypto
währungs meine hand crypto währungs
mining könnte island also zum new york
der krypto währungen werden aber wie ist
es überhaupt möglich dass ein so weit
abgelegen das land so wichtig für crypto
währungen sein kann nun in diesem video
werden wir es dir erklären
[Applaus]
[Musik]
island ist wahrlich eines der
ungewöhnlichsten länder der welt ein ort
an dem er als die hälfte der einwohner
an die existenz von elfen glaubt und zur
gleichen zeit ist ist eine der
fortschrittlichsten und modernsten
volkswirtschaften auf diesem planeten
egal welche methoden ansiehst island
belegt immer die spitzenplätze aller
rankings isländer sind reicher als
amerikaner oder dehnen und in bezug auf
einkommens gleichheit belegen sie platz
acht der weltrangliste
sie sind die unangefochtenen
spitzenreiter bei erneuerbaren energien
im grunde sind sie das einzige land der
erde dass sich rühmen kann das 100
prozent seiner energie komplett grün ist
und ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken ich land ist das nicht das land
das am meisten unter der großen
finanzkrise von 2008 geräten hat ja
genau wenn wir von island reden meinen
wir genau das land welches nach der
finanzkrise kompletten konkurs anmelden
musste doch in nur 13 jahren haben sie
alles wieder gewonnen was sie verloren
haben
wie haben sie das also fertig gebracht
wir werden uns in diesem team einen
anderen videos beschäftigen konnte
lassen wir es in nur drei worten
zusammen tourismus natürliche ressourcen
und korrektor währungen also aufgepasst
wie island das paradies der bitkom einer
wurde
es ist fast unmöglich eine genaue
berechnung zu machen wie viele bitcoins
oder die viele andere gruppierungen in
island gemeint werden aber es wird
geschätzt dass diese industrie fast ein
prozent des gesamten
bruttoinlandsprodukts des landes
ausmacht nach einigen schätzungen dann
in island 8 prozent aller heute
verwendeten bitcoins geschäft nicht
wiederhole das alles sind schätzungen
denn niemand hat genaue informationen
was wir sagen können ist dass island
innerhalb der klub der welt immer
wichtiger wird und es verfügt über eine
ganze reihe von vorteilen die es zum new
york der klub-boss machen könnten
die frage ist aber inwieweit ist für ein
ganzes land überhaupt gut es von
bitcoins abhängig zu sein
welchen einfluss könnte tritt kommt auf
die umwelt in island haben welche
vorteile haben die bitcoin island heute
werden wir alle diese fragen beantworten
aber zuerst wollen wir einen schnellen
blick in die geschichte werfen eines
sehr heißer markt von den ganzen
planeten
ich bin mir sicher dass viele von euch
schon gehört haben das bitcoin meiner
eine menge co2 emissionen erzeugen
richtig und einige von euch fragen sich
vielleicht warum eigentlich was hat mit
keulen mit umweltverschmutzung zu tun
und was zum teufel ist ein bitcoin
meiner einige von euch wissen dass alles
bestimmt schon aber damit wir alle auf
einem niveau sind wir weiter machen
lasst uns das mal kurz aufschlüssen
stellt uns vor ich schicke 100 euro an
einen freund jemand muss dafür
verantwortlich sagen diese transaktion
zu verifizieren
das heißt er muss sicherstellen dass ich
100 euro weniger auf seinem konto habe
und das 100 euro mehr auf dem konto
meines freundes sind wer kümmert sich
also um die authentifizierung dieser
transaktion nur im aktuellen
finanzsystem machen dass die banken
allerdings gibt es in der krypto welt
keine banken wer verifiziert also die
transaktion an dieser stelle kommen die
männer ins spiel
nein wir reden nicht über diese art von
meiner gemeint er diesen muss ich das
hauptmerkmal der krypto währung ist dass
alle nutzer eine kopie desselben ledger
ist also das logbuch aller bisher
getätigten transaktionen haben ja alle
transaktionen die in dieser gruppierung
im laufe der geschichte gemacht wurden
werden in diesem länger gespeichert das
bedeutet habe technisch gesehen könnte
jeder bitkom nutzer eine meiner sein wie
ideen also jenen aus der für die
verifizierung der transaktion
tatsächlich zuständig sein wird nun
durch wettbewerb das bild calls system
erstellt eine sehr komplizierte
mathematische gleichung der sogenannten
schuhwerk und der erste nutzer der sie
löst ist derjenige der für die
verifizierung der transaktionen dann
zuständig ist und was er hat diese
person im gegenzug nur zwei dinge zum
einen erhält er meine eine provision für
die transaktion bestätigt zum anderen
sind damit neu geschaffenen bitcoins
bezahlst du weißt ist die idee der
bitcoin dass insgesamt nur maximal 21
millionen bitcoins erzeugt werden können
diese bitcoins werden also erzeugt wenn
die männer bezahlt werden und deshalb
werden sie meiner genannt und ja ich
weiß das ist eine sehr einfache
erklärung wir haben eine menge dinge
ausgelassen aber das ist das
grundlegende konzept das zu verstehen
muss damit wir mit unserer geschichte
schnell weiter machen können nun wieder
dir vorstellen kannst wird die vom
system erzeugte mathematischer
rechenaufgabe nicht manuell gelöst das
heißt kein noch so kluges mädchen den
stift und papier und sei sich das größte
matthias wäre in der lage eine solche
gleichung in ihrer lebenszeit zu lösen
daher reden wir über probleme die nur
von computern gelöst werden können und
die leistungsträger der computer ist
desto schneller kann er sie lösen für
dir vorstellen kannst hat dies zu einem
verrückten wettrennen und wettrüsten
geführt wer den leistungsstärksten
computer hat um die reine vorstellung zu
geben so sehen bitcoin mining centre
heutzutage aus hast du hier siehst sind
hunderte von prozessoren grafikkarten
die unter einem dach zu einem
supercomputer zusammen gesichtet
supercomputer die bis zu 800 mal
schneller sein können als ein normaler
computer und hier kommt das
umweltproblem ins spiel denn wie du dir
vorstellen kannst verbrauchen diese
supercomputer eine menge energie
aber nicht nur das denn was passiert
wenn du hunderte solcher prozessoren 24
stunden am tag mit voller leistung
arbeiten lässt sie werden heiß und
müssen gekühlt werden du kannst dir also
vorstellen wieviel all diese bitcoin
meinungs- zentren für den betrieb von
klimaanlage
ausgeben mit anderen worten wenn du mit
kommen willst musst du besser sein
portemonnaie ost männliche stromrechnung
wird nicht billig doch mal einen blick
auf diese graf ja das ist richtig
laut einer schätzung der university of
cambridge verbrauchtes meinung von
bitcoin mehr energie als ein land wie
argentinien und all das erklärt danach
richten wie diese der ökologische
fußabdruck von bitcoin bedroht die
zukunft der währung also verstehst du
erstmal das problem liegt und was auf
denn wo es ein problem gibt gibt es auch
vielleicht eine lösung und hier kommt
der isländische faktor ins spiel
[Musik]
das laster billigen energie
ja in island liegen die grenzkosten der
stromerzeugung praktisch bei null
aber nicht nur dass 100 prozent der
verbrauchten energie ist grün
du hast mir nicht dann schau dir diese
nachricht an island bietet weltweit
einzigartige bedingungen für die
produktion von krupp bewährungen
aufkommen zu einer geothermischen
energie die sehr günstig und so 100
prozent erneuerbar ist und ich weiß was
du dich fragst was für eine art
schwarzer magie ist das was das land
getan und grüne sehr billige energie zu
haben
hier kommt der große vorteil des lebens
in der mitte des atlantiks island die
direkt an der bruchlinie die die
eurasische tektonische platte von der
nordamerikanischen tektonischen platte
trend ja das ist richtig es gibt
tatsächlich ein ort in island wo du hin
und her springen kannst und dabei
wechselweise erstmalig in eurasien und
jetzt wenn ich in nordamerika rufen
kannst und all das hat eine konsequenz
island ist eine vulkanische insel mit
enormer geothermischer aktivität wir
alle wissen ja island ist das land der
geysire heißen quellen und vulkane mit
unaussprechlichen namen all das macht es
nicht nur zu einem perfekten ort für
tourismus wir sprechen auch über
natürliche und erneuerbare
energiequellen aber das ist noch nicht
alles
eine weitere sache die isla
charakterisiert ist die kälte die
durchschnittliche jahrestemperatur liegt
bei etwa fünf grad was schafft eine
menge probleme aber rasch und es ist ein
riesiger vorteil weil du große server
kühlen willst oder große bild
konzentrieren
mit anderen worten es war nur eine frage
der zeit bis die nachrichten wie diese
finden sind
island ist ein land der vulkane geysire
und jetzt auch der bitcoins zum beispiel
genesis mining genesis meinung ist heute
eines der wichtigsten meinen unternehmen
der welt im jahr 2016 installierten sie
eine crypto währungs mining anlage
namens enigma sie meinen mit conny
serien und andere korrupte während 24
stunden am tag 365 tage im jahr
aber sie sind nicht die einzigen es
kommt immer häufiger vor dass man
nachrichten wie diese
meyers garten startet neue farben island
für cloud mining von bitcoin und theorie
um die vorteile und die rentabilität des
xoom allerdings in diesem land wurden
von verschiedenen unternehmen entdeckt
die alle ihren teil des kuchens haben
wollen aber eher dass du dich noch an
das problem des riesigen strombedarfs
könnte dies ein problem für island
darstellen
und noch einen blick auf das folgende
der bitkom energieverbrauch in island
worten einer lokalen firma die haushalte
überholen das stimmt die energie welche
die unternehmen ist dann verbrauchen
soll bereits die aller haushalte
übersteigen und du machst dich fragen wo
ist denn überhaupt das problem
schließlich um schöne saubere energie
wäre es nicht toll wenn alle mitkommen
meiner nach island ziehen würden nun
lasst uns jetzt mal einen blick auf die
kehrseite der medaille werden
die wall street der krypto währungen
[Musik]
es ist nicht das erste mal dass island
eine mächtige finanzindustrie hat das
letzte mal als isla die titelseiten der
finanzpresse in beschlag nahmen endete
dies im totalen bankrott wir werden die
ihr mehr über diese ganze saga in einem
kommenden video erzählen
die frage ist wie sind sie aus der krise
herausgekommen und die antwort lautet
dass die neue wirtschaftszweige gefunden
haben auf diesen und setzen können der
erste und bedeutendste ist der tourismus
wirft einen blick auf diese grafik
[Musik]
um die eine vorstellung zu geben 2014
noch island bereits mehr als eine
million touristen pro jahr an
das ist mehr als das dreifache der
einheimischen bevölkerung seit 2011 ist
der tourismus für jeden zweiten neu
geschaffenen arbeiten das im land
verantwortlich aber seit 2016 gibt es
einen weiteren noch vielversprechender
im sektor lauter icelandic blog chain
foundation wurden dort acht prozent
aller bitcoins geschäft mit
geothermischer und hydro elektrische
energie
es gibt schätzungen dass acht prozent
aller mit konz die gerade weltweit
geschützt werden aus island kommen und
isländische regierung hat diese
unternehmen mit offenen armen empfangen
aber macht das überhaupt sinn
[Musik]
nun in einem café mg bericht heißt es
dass die reseller persönlichen
rechenzentren im jahr 2016 also bevor
der aktuelle pop und wirklich einsetzte
bereits fast 1 prozent zum bip des
landes beigetragen haben
heute dürfte dieses jahr schon viel
höher liegen und ich weiß dass vielen
von euch jetzt durch den kopf geht
diejenigen von euch die politik schon
länger verfolgen können sie schon denken
was das problem ist und die linken unter
euch die neue frisur an politik sind
sollten jetzt schnell in a box
aktivieren und auch die kleine glocke
damit ihr keines unserer update verpasst
zum beispiel über island also viele von
euch werden denken dass das problem mit
konny island darin besteht dass das
ganze land am ende des von einer
einzigen industrie abhängig wird richtig
nun die wahrheit ist dass das noch
nichts droht vorerst hat island eine
sehr diversifizierte wirtschaft und es
ist schwer vorstellbar dass bitcoin das
wirklich ändern wird
ich war darüber lacht die meisten bitkom
einen unternehmen beschäftigen kaum
personal
mit anderen worten sie generieren eine
menge geld für das land aber die meisten
leute arbeiten in anderen bereichen
na dann ist doch alles in butter oder
gibt es doch noch ein problem und wird
einfach mal einen blick auf diese grafik
hier kannst du den energieverbrauch
island sind seit 2009 ist er wie
verrückt angestiegen aber warum in der
theorie wird der erste anstieg durch die
aluminiumproduktion begründet aluminium
war eine der ersten industrien welche
diesem land aus der krise geholfen haben
und diese branche verbraucht eine menge
energie
doch ab 2016 beginnt der
energieverbrauch noch weiter zu steigen
diese zeit herum beginnen sich die
bitcoin meiner im land niederzulassen
das heißt mit der ankunft bitkom
startups ist die nachfrage in die höhe
geschnellt und folgendes passiert die
nordische region die grüne oase des
bitcoins hat keinen stromüberschuss mehr
ja das stimmt aluminium und das bitcoin
mal bringt die versorgung des landes mit
grüner energie an ihre grenzen und du
fragst dich vielleicht ob crypto
währungen den energiebedarf wirklich so
stark erhöht haben nun wirft einen blick
auf diese grafik hier kannst du sehen
wie der energieverbrauch muss zur arbeit
und rechenzentren jahr für jahr und 50
prozent wächst und ja das sind vor allem
crypto meiner all das bedeutet dass
dieses land früher oder später seine
stromerzeugung erhöhen muss und die
frage lautet ob sie es überhaupt
schaffen noch mehr grüne energie zu
produzieren und die antwort lautet ja
nicht nur aus der geothermie können sie
mir herausholen island fängt auch an die
windkraftanlagen zu bauen
denn bis vor ein paar wenigen jahren
hatte ich schwierigkeiten
windkraftanlage zu installieren und
warum wird dort kein wind nun ganz im
gegenteil es gibt einfach keine
windkraftanlagen welche den stürmen die
auf der insel auftreten standhalten
können jetzt aber gibt es eine
technologie die es möglich macht
windparks in tesla zu bauen
mit anderen worten das problem ist nicht
die umwelt es ist auch nicht der mangel
an diversifikation aber wo verdammt noch
mal wo ist das problem mag bitter erlöse
uns von unserem leid verrat uns doch
endlich okay nun das problem ist was
wäre wenn crypto während eines tages
nicht mehr so profitabel wären stellt
das war so vor den letzten jahren sind
sowohl bitcoin also auch andere
gruppierungen in erstaunliche höhen
gestiegen
das hat viele unternehmer dazu
veranlasst aus zu springen und riesige
neuen kulturzentrum zu errichten
bislang musste deswegen neuer kraftwerke
und stromgeneratoren bauen aber was wäre
wenn der krypto boom eines tages zu ende
geht was würde dann mit all der
installierten energieinfrastruktur
passieren kann dass ich weiß dass viele
von euch denken dass crypto wir hier
sind um zu bleiben
aber seien wir mal ehrlich keiner von
uns weiß was in der zukunft passieren
wird und es ist sehr vernünftig
anzunehmen dass selbst wenn es in 20
jahren noch gibt das meinen nicht mehr
so profitabel sein
wird wie jetzt jeder kann dazu seine
eigene meinung haben aber es ist
unbestreitbar das ist eine mehr als
wahrscheinliche möglichkeit ist
schließlich wäre es nicht das erste mal
dass auf den trip to be mine jahrelange
eindruck folgt und in diesem fall
was würde island mit allen investitionen
machen die es getätigt hat windräder
halten nicht ewig und ihre
instandhaltung ist ein teurer spaß für
diesen problemen konfrontiert gibt es
zwei mögliche lösungen die erste ist
dass island den export von grüner
energie in andere länder in betracht
zieht doch stromübertragung mit hilfe
von unterseekabeln wäre zu teuer
die einzige praktikable lösung wäre
wasserstoff der dann in die ganze welt
exportiert werden kann
hierzu müssen jedoch erst mal die
globale wasserstoffwirtschaft in schwung
kommen wir haben jetzt so vor einigen
wochen bereits ein video gedreht welches
du dir über den link oben links ansehen
kannst die zweite option ist dass der
staat für keiner dieser windräder
bezahlt das heißt das ist die bitcoin
meiner selbst wären die für ihre eigenen
energiequellen bezahlen müssen
[Musik]
diese lösung könnte sehr attraktiv sein
denn sie würde es erlauben so viele
bitkom einer wie nötig zu installieren
allerdings konnte dieses land wieder
weniger attraktive profitable für die
krypto welt machen
außerdem könnten anderen ortes schöna
die norwegen an eine eine bessere option
darstellen daher ist die frage jetzt an
dich gerichtet was denkst du sollte
island tun glaubst du dass es eine gute
sache ist wenn der isländische staat auf
crypto währungen setzen und wildparks
baut die aus westlichen geldern
finanziert werden oder wäre es besser
wenn diese windparks privat von den
bitcoin meiner selbst errichtet werden
mit anderen worten bitkom einer würden
die energie die sie verbrauchen selbst
verwalten und wird island die neue wall
street view währungen werden und werden
sie dann in der lage sein den
energiebedarf zu decken
ich teile deine meinung wird mit uns und
auch in anderen im kommentarbereich hast
du dieses video etwas gebracht hat gibt
ihm ein schönes kleid und vergiss nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren mach's gut
und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]